in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Jeremy
and Kristen are with us hey guys how are
ya hi Dave hey Dave
welcome welcome where do you live we're
from Louisville Kentucky all right very
cool welcome it's good to have you here
to do your debt-free scream we are and
how much have you paid off
we paid off two hundred and ninety five
thousand dollars Wow how long did that
take it took 70 months just a little
listen six years gotcha okay and making
what kind of money during that time we
started off about 115 and we got a
little bit of an increase up to 185
excellent excellent
so I'm guessing this is your house and
everything actually it's not it's mostly
student loans
who's the doc I'm the doctor she's the
lawyer Oh wanna be okay Wow
it's almost like paying off a house
there a couple of them Wow okay so we've
been fighting our way through this and
that's how you got this great income
though that's good news
and for six years from Law School in med
school there we go so I have you both
been out for six years both in
practicing yes yeah I've been out eight
I think okay all right very cool so you
you said you're the doc and she's the
lawyer yeah is that right okay cool fine
Wow well I would ask what started you on
this journey but I think I know
$295,000 really stood one day but how
did you what made you think you could
pay it off this fast because most people
they just keep it your contemporaries
they just keep it around don't they well
and that was our plan to start with we
you know we're signed up for that
standard 30-year repayment with Sallie
Mae yeah we just thought you know we'll
buy house will buy some cars will
finance everything just like everybody
else does and then one day we were in
church and we listened to the sermon we
came home we were sitting at the table
together and I looked at him and I said
I think we need to pay off her debt and
he said you know I had the same message
today during the sermon so at that point
we looked to each other and we knew we
needed to pay off this debt and we
needed to do it just as quickly as we
could cool so what what did you do after
that did you get involved in the
financial piece are you listening the
show or do you just do it on your own or
what well we we'd been listening to the
show already but we went out and we got
the book and sat down and said
plan okay just like that very cool what
do you guys go to church we go to the
southeast Christian Church
oh yeah yeah good friends of ours good
folks pastor stone yeah Dave yeah good
folks good people and a ham this is a
lot yeah this is a lot I mean how does
that feel you got a fuel free yeah it
feels amazing now you know when we have
our monthly budget meetings instead of
sitting down and fighting about who's
going to get personal cash and what it's
going to be we're talking about what
we're gonna get to do with our money
that we want to do so it's really
exciting yeah that is a song that's
awesome I mean you can do this you can
do anything
I mean you've climbed the mountain I
mean this is amazing yeah very cool so
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is because you paid
off $295,000 that just blows your mind
well really for us we had right after we
got out of school the recession hit and
I was in practice and a part-time
position and I realized that my dream of
being a full-time doctor in that
practice wasn't going to be realized
whoa so we had to make a really tough
decision I was offered a really really
really good position in another city a
hundred miles away from where we had
always said we were gonna live for the
rest of our lives and so I prayed about
it and God said go so I went and he took
care of the rest of the details but we
had to live apart for a year during this
time Oh going to a city that I didn't
know anyone and I didn't have any idea
what I was going to do but we had this
goal together that we were going to get
out of debt and we're gonna do as soon
as possible and God took care of the
rest so that that unable to make good
money to be able to attack this for a
year and then you found something back
in Louisville move back no that's that's
where we move oh you both eventually
joined you eventually joined me yeah I
see okay very cool man that's important
well you you have to make decisions like
that and in order to sacrifices in order
to get there and you guys definitely did
that very cool and that's what we tell
people the key is there's three things
that we based our our hold debt-free
opportunity on the first one was
teamwork working together as a team
making sure that everyone in the house
is on the the budget is on the plan
together not just us but the kids as
well they were a part of it and we
wanted them to be as involved as
possible and part of that involves
sacrifice we had to put the needs of the
family ahead of each of our own
individual once and that was really hard
at times it was hard for the kids it was
hard for us but we had a common goal
when we work toward it together and we
had perseverance as long as we continued
all together as a family with God all
things as possible mm-hmm
Kristen sounds like he was on fire he
was leading the charge well he was
leading the charge and he has the
spreadsheets to prove it's very cool
well if the guys riding down the hill on
a white horse screaming at the top of
his lungs with his sword drawn people
will follow that's what it comes down to
so good job good job there's a lot of
courage is contagious and it really is
that's that's amazing well
congratulations you two
I'm very very proud of you and Zach and
Emily are the two kids is that right are
they gonna join you they're gonna join
us because they've joined in the
sacrifice to get here that's right and
how old are they Zach is 10 and Emily is
8 okay so have they been practicing
their debt-free scream oh they've been
practicing because the whole family
trees changed here and you're not
allowed to be bored you have to actually
act like you care about this so all
right Jeremy a Christian local Kentucky
$295,000 paid off in seven years or
seven six years 70 months 115 up to 180
$5,000 household income count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream ready
well done you guys